no final dos anos 90 viveu algum tempo
em buenos aires onde eu dirigia um pólo
de produção internacional
os clientes vinham por conta do câmbio
baixo e pelas vagas da variedade de
locações são lugares pra filmar mas eles
também viviam os cruzavam o equador
motivados não só por causa disso eles
também viviam para cliente e
respeitadora noite portenha
alguns foram para a noite de buenos
aires e nunca mais foram vistos
como se não bastasse o choque entre
culturas havia nas filmagens uma tensão
nem sempre sutil entre inovadores e
conservadores já que a maioria dos
técnicos que vinham de fora
respirava que o fez uma oração respirava
flávia respira respirava os técnicos
respiravam os primeiros ares da era
digital enquanto os locais eram de uma
escola
buenos aires argentina totalmente
tradicional pra não dizer irrascível
mente tradicional não se pode porque no
porquê num peru que roni não porque não
porque há cá não se com ele
não porque não parece resposta que se dá
uma criança e ainda assim não há
qualquer criança lembro da indignação
que sentia desde pequena eu já fui
pequena com a imposição de limites em
uma razão clara
gente eu nasci em porto alegre na virada
dos anos 60 e sempre fui andrógena isso
significa que eu sou phd em bullying
a escola pio 12 ipa com especialização
em novo porque nom as brincadeiras de
tarefas do repertório disponível por uma
menina de 67 anos já não me entusiasma
vão naquela época eu só queria brincar
na rua subir em árvore jogar futebol
coisa de guri e que uma menina não pode
impor que não só que eu jogava muito bom
uma vez me fazendo passar por um guri
escondida entre os meus amigos de time
de rua eu joguei toda a fase
classificatória do campeonato
dente-de-leite popular é importante até
ser descoberto se imagina a situação
quando a gente começou a jogar em
lugares melhores e tal tinha aquela
situação do vestiário me enfiava dentro
do guarda roupa para não ver o júri
pelado para o horror eu fui descoberta
claro né
o horror e vergonha das minhas tias que
viviam enchendo a cabeça da minha mãe
que tentava qualquer costume fazer usar
saia
aliás é a primeira vez que eu estou
usando saia e anos em homenagem a você
está
ela queria que usa saia pelo menos
flávia na festa de aniversário da sua
prima minha mas só me convenceu
no dia que ela me mostrou na barça e
ilustrações ruins de legionários romanos
vestidos de saiote que ele ia ainda veio
de vestido
eu não sou linda eu sou uma lesionada
romana
eu não queria ser o menino gente mas
tampouco queria ser enquadrada e
limitada ao padrão feminino
definitivamente eu não cabia e nenhum
dos dois modelos estéticos e de
comportamento disponíveis na época e me
dou conta que mesmo sem querer minha
própria existência sempre provocou e
desorganizou a ordem das mínimas coisas
ao meu redor e de algumas certezas
absolutas ou seja não adianta eu sou
discutir viva por natureza e eu preciso
confessar a vocês que estou me sentindo
aliás muito bem nesse cenário onde somos
obrigados a nos inventar e reinventar a
cada vez mais rápido e conforme se para
todo o sempre
aliás falar na velocidade em que o mundo
está mudando já é lugar comum
na verdade precisamos prestar atenção na
aceleração essa sim me impressiona pois
não só a velocidade é exponencial
a aceleração segundo haiku israel
futurista americano e nosso colega de
ted os próximos 100 anos
nos próximos cem anos o professor
gustavo conferiu a informação nos
próximos 100 anos
era o impacto de inovação equivalente
aos últimos 20 mil anos
ou seja o impacto de inovação a cada ano
a partir de agora será o equivalente a
18 anos
um ano 200 anos
como que eu vou explicar aspas minhas
tias né e como explicar também o fato de
que o meu dna discutivo sempre foi uma
vantagem competitiva nem communication
revolution
o estudo que eu vou apresentar nasceu
com o intuito de encontrar respostas e
construir uma base teórica para essa
quase impossível tarefa que é inovar em
plena era da aceleração no meu querido
estado
um dos grandes responsáveis por este
cenário vertiginoso aliás chama se 27 e
é nada mais nada menos do que um dos
pais da internet durante a entrevista
que eles nos que ele nos concedeu na
califórnia ano passado ele nos disse que
o poder não está na informação o poder
está na informação compartilhada é
portanto um privilégio estar aqui no
palco do texas nos ensinos muito
obrigada enfim um tapete vermelho gente
pra compartilhar com vocês de
communication um revolução
em 2013 o mundo nas ruas que em tempos
incompreensível e foi lenta
foi quando caímos na estrada tentando
entender as grandes transformações na
indústria da comunicação
mas os reflexos dessas mudanças no
comportamento de quem produz e distribui
informação
o que muda na cabeça de quem consome
notícia e opinião que destinos terão
novas e velhas formas de comunicar
durante dez meses ouvimos e registramos
as opiniões de comunicadores geeks
futuristas filósofos pesquisadores
jornalistas universitários e
historiadores mais de 300 horas de
entrevistas no brasil e nos estados
unidos
o resultado aqui está o registro
histórico sem censura cultural
colaborativo beca totalmente frito e
compartilhado na rede
aliás como deve ser de communication
revolution um estudo que não traz
verdades absolutas propõe 11 premissas
que servirão de base para que você
chegue às suas próprias conclusões sobre
este mundo que aí está e se reinventa a
todo instante
o novo ser humano é dotado de novas
habilidades cognitivas entre elas um
bush de técnico que maximiza o
pensamento crítico rejeitar mentiras e
para o relevante do neném
a transparência é hoje um critério
obrigatório e inegociável
por isso não tenho outra alternativa
senão falar verdade e desde já deixar
claro que esta não é exatamente uma
apresentação linear
as pessoas podem não concordar com o que
você pensa mas precisam confiar em você
já que a segunda premissa afirma que
credibilidade passou a ser o principal
ativo de marcas e profissionais deixou
todos que me permitam conduzi los por
essa narrativa cujo objetivo é testar a
capacidade multi leitura de vocês
além de tentar driblar a limitação de
tempo da minha apresentação
o meu plano é apresentar as 11 premissas
de tcr na tela e enquanto
simultaneamente fácil no palco uma
derivação do conteúdo só vai funcionar
se derrubarmos a quarta parede ou seja
se você embarcarem na brincadeira
lessa a terceira premissa de tcr aponta
a participação como tendência
transformadora e disse que o poder agora
na proximidade na integração e no
compartilhamento na internet inaugurou
um movimento global pela pluralidade e
entenda se por pluralidade não apenas a
diversidade e nossa necessidade de
entender todos os ângulos de todos os
assuntos mas também a pluralidade da
linguagem que deixou de ser linear e
agora se manifesta múltipla fragmentada
intermitente gerando comportamentos que
podem ser percebidos como
esquizofrênicos como essa apresentação
a estamos reinventando a noção que
tínhamos de tempo espaço graças às
nossas telas móveis o padrão linear de
leitura flui nas ruas e agora
fragmentação nos obriga obriga nossas
mentes cartesianas a se adaptarem e
produzirem a integração necessária a
imagem por exemplo ganha um protagonismo
impressionante é o eixo central da
transformação da linguagem
nosso desafio é entender seus novos usos
afinal ao contrário da escrita a imagem
não é precisa a imagem é um biguá
mas é fato que a linguagem transformada
aumentou nossa percepção de forma
exponencial
confirmando que show o estado beta é
permanente eu fiz essa galinha só o
estado deve ser permanente e que o
definitivo é provisório onde eu estou
querendo chegar
basicamente na idéia de que querendo ou
não gostando ou não você já está a
transformar o fato de que está
acompanhando essa apresentação
multiplayer é a prova disso
inovação é evolução garotada e não vamos
diariamente inadvertidamente até pensar
à frente está longe de ser um pensamento
confortável é verdade porém lamento
informar inevitável ccr foi sem dúvida
uma experiência extraordinária
que impacto e muito o nosso jeito de
interpretar o tempo em que vivemos mas
acima de tudo gerou em nós um grande
questionamento sobre propósito ea
certeza de que está mais do que na hora
de adotarmos um ideário orientado para a
felicidade e para a urgente revelou são
da sociedade
eu disse ao gent reinvenção da sociedade
um bom exemplo de reinvenção
é emergente economia da colaboração é
provável que uma das mais importantes
facetas dessa força transformadora seja
o fato de que tudo o que é tangível e
intangível
agora posso fazer parte de um mercado
baseado na colaboração e é justamente no
valor do interlegis viveu que começa o
declínio da cultura econômica que só
valoriza o tangível e que se limita às
suas moedas
talvez esse flerte com o abstrato seja
um sinal sutil sutil de que estamos nos
permitindo expandir as nossas percepções
e no short a nossa intuição
afinal precisamos reaprender uma visão
não linear mais espontânea anárquica e
intuitiva
a intuição buscar as respostas onde elas
geralmente estão no espaço invisível que
conecta um ponto ao outro
a utilidade é percepção
ela não está no que você realiza mas no
modo como o que você realiza é percebido
pelos demais
recentemente alguém me perguntou o que o
grupo ganha ao compartilhar
gratuitamente esse estudo e dei conta de
que o estudo seria muito mais útil do
que eu imaginava porque justamente esse
tipo de percepção que precisa mudar
ao construir uma ferramenta e
disponibilizá la ao mercado o ganho
revelou é de todos
assim é o admirável mundo novo de
communication revolution nos ensina que
a face mais revolucionária deste mundo
não é tecnológica é comportamental
estamos resgatando fundamentos sociais
que estavam esquecidos como o
compartilhamento ea colaboração mas
acima de tudo o empoderamento do
indivíduo ea valorização da expressão
humana e em toda a sua diversidade
desculpa cunha desculpa com isso minha
intuição
minha intuição me diz que a inovação é
libertação a inovação é libertação
o inovador é livre no sentido mais
espontâneo e original da palavra
o inovador é uma criança que
simplesmente é que ousa que desafia e
arrisca porque sim sim não porque não
portanto libertem-se muito obrigado